pourquoi c'est arrivé
elle aime pas la littérature cette fille
qui me posent cette question j'ai
vraiment envie de partir
si j'avais su j'aurais pas venu
seulement je vais quand même rester
parce que j'ai quand même envie d'avoir
de la presse c'est pour mon livre je
laime mon livre c'est tout mais elle
n'aime pas et on s'aimera jamais elle
sait vous une type est elle la
journaliste on a un nom alors au ballon
et vous c'est qui abbas et moi c'est moi
je suis écrivain voilà et elle sait à
peine un être humain tout les
journalistes sont comme ça quand elle
veut le faire je crois pas que toutes
les journalistes comme ça non c'est pas
seulement la question de ça c'est il ya
des gens c'est pas seulement de
journalistes il ya aussi des écrivains
comme ça qu'ils ont perdu à ce que
j'appelle le noyau dur c'est à dire
cette chose qui fait que ben on épure
quand même quand même oui mais qu'est ce
qui lui est arrivé à la narratrice
elle s'est fait bouffer le noyau dur je
suis sûr qu'elle là encore il s'est fait
bouffer comment
non en fait là j'ai fait une confusion
la narratrice elle n'a à son noyau dur
la journaliste qui s'est fait pousser
mais la narratrice
ben tout va bien tout va bien les balles
et jamais rien arrivé donc sa fille si
plein de choses la question et
j'arrivais tout un tas de choses
et alors à l'écrit mais à tout le monde
y avait un tas de choses mais elle a
besoin de doubler sa vie elle a besoin
d'écrire parce qu'elle est très très
vieille s'il faut être très très vieux
pour écrire peut peut-être un peu mort
déjà pour écrire et alors bon voilà elle
a eu envie de mourir donc alors sa
familiarité total ce genre de choses là
en plus dans son appartement à elle où
elle a pris son fauteuil pour se
permettre de poser ces questions-là
mais pourquoi cette fille mme keller de
vous ressembler beaucoup
manifestement elle accepte de livrer sa
vie mme à une journaliste pour son livre
j'ai dit tout à l'heure parce que ray
pub non pas pour faire la pub pour aller
vers les lecteurs
parce que le lecteur alors ça c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qu'elle aime
alors ils vont de voile dissipons de
mystère vous appelez christine angot où
vous venez publiés
un livre qui s'intitule interview qui
paraît chez fayard ces jours ci je ne
sais pas si c'est vous mais vous
raconter une interview avec une
journaliste pose des questions à une
narratrice et à cette narratrice il est
arrivé quelque chose est-ce qu'on peut
le nommer sur sa pelle l'inceste
à la fin ça tient huit pages c'était pas
la peine de poser des questions pendant
quatre heures tourner autour du pot pour
savoir si ça se passait à l'hôtel ou si
ça se passait pas à l'hôtel c'était dans
une chambre où deux chambres taylor
s'est passé au dessus d'une pizzeria
d'après ce que j'ai compris non avant
val attendait là non j'ai pas retenu ce
à quoi vous écrivez vous écrivez depuis
longtemps je crois que c'est votre
quatrième livre oui on a l'impression
que vous revenez sans cesse sur ce qui
vous est arrivé
l'inceste non en fait là ce qui s'est
passé c'est que on m'avait dit qu'il
fallait pas le faire c'est à dire que la
jolie et 6 secondes de l'inceste c'est
ça non la journaliste elle voulait que
je le dise parce que c'était bien
socialement parce que ça pouvait aider
d'autres femmes mais moi je ne suis pas
qu on appelle ça assistante sociale
donc ça m'intéressait pas d'aider
d'autres femmes et alors donc j'ai pas
voulu
j'ai dit non dans ce cas et d'un autre
côté sur le plan de la littérature
l'éditeur disait qu'il fallait pas en
parler dans le livre parce que ça
n'intéressait pas les gens parce que on
allait me réduire à ça et alors donc je
les fais là pour le coup puisqu'il
fallait pas le faire pour bien enfoncer
le clou pour dire une chose une seule
chose à quoi je tiens c'est que c'est
moi qui commande c'est l'auteur qui
commande c'est ni la journaliste qui
disent qu'il faut écrire
lecteurs quelques faubert électeurs
comme mon père il a commandé un moment
et vous a commandé à un moment il ya des
chances
ouais mais là on tombe dans la
confidence et ça si on va prendre un
café tout à l'heure peut-être on en
parlera
mais pour l'instant la sai on prend des
risques graves là qu'on risque de sortir
du livre est le livre c'est l'espace de
liberté totale
si on commence à rentrer dans la
confidence on va perdre cette chance de
liberté serait dommage est-ce que ça
fait du bien d'écrire ce qui vous est
arrivé
est-ce que ça éloigne ce qui s'est passé
elle me ramène toujours à cette histoire
quoi autrement dit c'est pour ça que
vous écrivez mais va savoir c'est
peut-être parce que cette tête peut-être
que j'écris parce qu'il m'est arrivé ça
et peut-être que il m'est arrivé ça
parce que je suis écrivain
moi je crois que c'est plutôt ça
l'interdît de l'inceste permettent
permet de comprendre l'interdît
artistique à savoir ne pas questionner
l'auteur sur sa vie mais sur ses livres
l'américaine fois c'est ses livres
[Musique]